it has been exactly one week since the
family of a Florida tourist name was
Carla Stefani AK heard from her she went
missing on a trip in Costa Rica now
police they're working to identify a
body that was found near a rental home
where she had stayed she went to Costa
Rica to celebrate her birthday and well
will her cause is in Key Biscayne
Florida that's near Stefani X home and
well good morning good morning there is
still no official confirmation the body
found in costa rica is that of Stefani
ACK identification is expected later
today but even before Monday's discovery
her relatives told us they suspected
foul play at the last place she was
apparently seen alive Karla Stefani AX
father spoke of his family's heartbreak
before the announcement of a grim
discovery her mom is absolutely
devastated she tends to be around noon
Monday police in Costa Rica confirmed
that search dogs found a partially
buried female body covered with plastic
bags in a wooded area near this Airbnb
property outside san jose it is the same
location where Stefani act checked in
last Tuesday the last eight family
members heard from her some competitors
con Sangeeta
a representative with Costa Rica's
judicial investigation agency says a
search inside the apartment found
biological fluids compatible with blood
secondary the hot springs
Stefani ACK had spent most of the week
in Costa Rica with her sister-in-law who
left a day early an avid user of social
media Stefaniuk stopped all
communication the night she checked into
the Airbnb
her brother Carlos Caicedo spoke with us
on Sunday after traveling to the Central
American country he says he spoke with
the property owner about what his
security guards told him about Stefani X
departure but both Chi seto and his wife
who had been traveling with Stefani ACK
are skeptical she would leave that early
because her flight wasn't scheduled
until more than eight hours later so we
don't know if it's the guards we don't
know
Airbnb guy we don't know if it's both
someone's not telling the truth because
that's not in her character this morning
her family members who are now in Costa
Rica sent us a statement saying they are
on their way to meet with authorities to
try to identify the body
Airbnb says it has extended its support
to the family as well as authorities in
Costa Rica and here in the US fionna man
they were thinking of her family
especially her mom this morning thank
you